well guys if there's one thing that the
great gatsby has taught me it's that
people in the 20s really liked jay-z
music quite a bit actually the Great
Gatsby is directed by Baz Luhrmann and
it stars leonardo dicaprio tobey maguire
carey mulligan and joel edgerton this is
yet another adaptation of the book by
the same name that came out in the 20s
many people refer to that book as a
literary classic and so a lot of the
fans of that book are very concerned
whenever another adaptation pops up will
it live up to the book they're going to
capture the same feeling is it going to
change it what's it going to do now for
those who are unfamiliar the plot of the
movie is about a bond salesman his name
is Nick Carraway played by Tobey Maguire
and he moves into this small little
house and the next-door neighbor of him
is James Gatsby or Leonardo DiCaprio's
character he lived in this giant mansion
and he has these lavish parties like
every night where people just come to
his house uninvited and it's like a
small mini nation jazz music is just now
becoming popular they're having these
giant giant parties next door and Tobey
Maguire's character is sort of thrown
into this situation he receives the one
and only invite that anyone's ever
actually gotten from mr. Gatsby himself
he comes to this party and discovers
that mr. Gatsby has a plan for him and I
won't tell you what it is we don't know
what it is basically the large majority
of the film revolves around romantic
backstabbing of sorts but large themes
of the book and the themes of this movie
are kind of like introducing yourself to
a new different type of society and
showing what different societies that
people were like back in those days and
how they interacted with each other and
what the repercussions of living that
kind of life could be so let's just get
into how faithful is this movie to the
source material in regards to what
happens in the book and what happens in
the movie extremely faithful it's
basically the exact same plot the same
events happen they do a really good job
of recreating the events that are in the
book in regards to selling the emotional
weight of the book I don't really think
this film reaches that there are
elements of this film that feel really
bloated really exaggerated and just way
way to over produced certain parts of
this movie I thought were very
impressive the performances were very
good but everything felt a little bit
too big at first and I understand that
you may say well that's kind of how the
book is it's showing you how big and
larger-than-life a lot of these people
were back then and how they were getting
so into this party scene and everything
was
big the thing is this movie feels way
too modern to be able to sell the whole
1920s era for one the entire movie is
filled with jay-z music a very talented
musician I don't have anything against
him but I just don't really feel like
his music you know in 1920s I don't it
just didn't really mesh for me it seemed
like it was trying to modernize the tale
too much and appeal to a younger
demographic which I understand from a
business standpoint but selling the
whole 1920s thing and the fact that it
feels like 75 to 80 percent of this
movie was shot on a green-screen
soundstage really lost a lot of realism
for me the whole movie felt kind of fake
there are really impressive visuals in
this movie but the best scenes in this
film are the ones where you can tell
they actually shot that in a real room
somewhere or on an actual constructed
set somewhere and not in like some giant
green-screen environment those scenes
felt fake unrealistic and filled with
sensory overload and a lot of that is
Baz Luhrmann style if you've seen Moulin
Rouge or Romeo and Juliet or Australia
or his early hit Strictly Ballroom he
has a very in-your-face look at this
look at that look at this with all these
colors would be this big stuff style and
he definitely has a vision and he
portrays it fairly well in this movie
and he doesn't disrespect the source
material my main problem with this film
is this and it's my best way to describe
to you why I didn't enjoy the film as
Lerman seemed so intent on showing you
this humongous vision all these special
effects CGI green screens stuff flying
everywhere camera tricks that I think he
lost sight of the raw human emotion and
the characters at the central part of
this story that really make this story
work and I feel like that is where this
movie really sidestepped itself the
director was in the way too much this
was not an actors movie despite all the
talented people in this movie I was
rarely ever really taken by any of their
performances despite the fact that I
felt that they were all doing a pretty
good job the film's CGI and added
elements and overuse of 3d effects just
really felt like it was like look at all
this stuff I'm throwing at you but it
didn't feel like it had any substance it
seemed all style to me about the 3d it
is good
it's got great depth of field and there
were some moments where you really feel
like you're immersed in the shot but
this movie just had way too much style
over substance for me to the point where
I couldn't latch on to any of the real
emotion that these actors were
praying and despite the fact the story
had a lot of real drama in it it's the
vision that the filmmaker had while
impressive it just seemed like it kept
getting in the way
DiCaprio is great in this film his
performance is really good as gatsby one
of the things I thought the movie did a
really good job portraying was that
mystery around his character because
takes a while to introduce him you just
hear about him you see maybe his hand
like looking through the blinds but you
don't see his face they really did a
good job of setting up the character and
making you have a lot of mystery about
him and I like that I think Tobey
Maguire was a good choice for this movie
and I'll tell you why I see his
character is the person that we see
through as the audience were the people
who through him go Wow look at that look
at that and he's the guy first
experiencing all of this new world and
we're there with him and Tobey Maguire
is really good at portraying a sense of
innocence like he did with Peter Parker
and spider-man and I think that he did a
good job doing that in this movie as
well Carey Mulligan great in shame Drive
she did a pretty good job in this movie
too but I feel like her character was a
little bit under written and maybe a
little bit robotic because there were
times in the movie where she felt so
enamored with Leonardo DiCaprio's
character and there were times where she
didn't care I don't really know if
that's so much just her character being
so despicable but I feel like her
character just wasn't really written
that well Joel Edgerton did a great job
in this movie he played this really
terrible guy named Tom who was always in
the middle of everything causing all
these problems with the relationships
between these two people and man he did
a really good job in this movie I was
really impressed with his performance
because I've liked Joel Edgerton and
everything I've seen but I honestly
started to hate that character in this
movie and he did a great job of
portraying that all in all the great
gatsby has a lot of impressive things
about it but there's just way too much
of the director getting in the way in my
opinion to fully recommend the film to
you so I'm going to give the Great
Gatsby a C+ I think it's a film worth
seeing I just feel like there were some
problems with the vision of the main
story and the director and the actors
and not all of it seemed to be very
cohesive because it seemed like the
director was just getting in there way
too much so thanks a lot for watching
guys when you see the film let me know
what you think or what your thoughts on
the book are or maybe the Robert Redford
adaptation of the same film or any of
the many adaptations we've had through
TV or straight-to-dvd or whatever
there's a ton trust me I got to do is
search Great Gatsby on IMDB and it's
like well it'll even do that sound
oh no I mom as always guys thanks for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck Minh eyes